also today coming to america started
streaming with a lot of familiar faces
and a couple of new ones yes indeed like
wesley snipes who was
this close to being in the first one
i think you told me that you tried out
for the first coming to america i'm
am i wrong i'm not wrong that's facts
that's facts it was me eric lasalle
and mario van peeples and eric lasalle
won the role
i pretty much hate him ever since take
care of this for me will you
actually me eric lasalle are very good
friends general izzy would love nothing
more than to take over zamunda
wesley had to wait 33 years for a role
in coming to america
so how to get the park dolomite was my
audition
for this role jibber jammer thank you mr
murphy
thank you sir and no one is more excited
than eddie for this sequel streaming now
on prime video
maybe because it's kept him distracted
from another big event in his life okay
so eddie
i gotta ask you because you know you
have a milestone birthday coming up in
april
60. listen
what can we expect from 60 to 70. he
gotta come into america three in his
head
you know what oh we i swear
there's a there's a part three but it
doesn't happen for 16 years
it's i have to be 75
what's in the immediate future i want to
do stand up again
the plan was to do dolomite to do
saturday night live and do coming to
america then
do up and then kobe did so we had to you
know
put that on hold bye-bye